[Musique]
cette semaine je veux parler du serment
d'allégeance dont on entend beaucoup
parler dernièrement on s'entend que la
discussion autour de est-ce que des
personnes qui sont souvenissent
idéologiquesment peuvent porter un
serment d'allégeance sans justement
faire dans le fond par jour dire quelque
chose qui n'est pas vrai et je dois
comprendre vraiment l'enjeu parce que
pendant des années on avait l'idéologie
derrière laquelle on prenait on prenait
serment face à la reine
la reine c'était déjà quelque chose
d'autre que le roi Charles qui est un
personnage beaucoup plus public beaucoup
moins neutre dans sa représentation car
la reine a toujours gardé une posture
très neutre très elle savait faire
l'équilibre entre ce qu'elle présentait
publiquement est-ce qu'elle présentait
de sa vie privée on s'entend que dans le
code Charles sa vie privée
Camilla la princesse Diana ses fils
c'est le mystère autour de la royauté de
ce qui était quand même un objet de
neutralité quand c'était la reine qui
représentait était beaucoup moins
difficile à gober que présentement
portait allégeance à Charles déjà je
pars de cette idéologie là dans une
société où tout est connu tout est su on
connaît la marque de tes sous-vêtements
s'il faut et bien prêter l'urgence à un
être vivant aussi
dans l'imaginaire des gens ça c'est
compréhensible déjà que ça fait un
premier pas en tant que canadien en tant
que québécois en tant que souv business
ou en tant que même autochtone t'es
comme déjà c'est pas la reine mais là on
rentre dans l'idée de la souveraineté de
se porter par jour certaines personnes
veulent faire le serment mais loin des
caméras pour ne pas avoir être filmé
c'est un peu comme avoir un test médical
tu as pas envie que tout le monde te
regarde quand c'est si j'ai un an que ça
de porter à les gens à justement une
institution qui est aussi
vétuste pour beaucoup et qui représente
quand même aussi le fait qu'on les lois
changent les sociétés changent les codes
de culturels changent et donc ce qui
était la reine il y a 50 ans et ce qui
est le roi aujourd'hui c'est deux choses
complètement différentes et en tant
qu'individu en tant que personne qui
font partie d'une fédération du
fédéralisme
et aussi du fait que beaucoup de gens
pas seulement au Québec mais je parle
dans d'autres provinces ont des rêves de
souveraineté d'avoir des provinces ayant
plus de pouvoir que le un pays qui est
le Canada ou même que elle a souveraine
ou le souverain excusez-moi c'est des
discussions qui peuvent avoir mais moi
ce que je vais arriver c'est quand même
langue autochtone de ceci parce que ça
va être très intéressant vu qu'on a
notre première femme autochtone élue et
moi ce que ça le Sony comme alarme ce
que je veux toujours qu'on fasse
attention c'est l'instrumentalisation de
l'identité autochtone ou plutôt donner
dans ce cas-ci de l'identité d'indienne
inscrite excusez-moi parce que la loi
sur mes indiens existent encore dans son
ce terme-là qu'est-ce que ça représente
de porter allégeance pas uniquement à
titre de de
représentants de ton parti politique
mais aussi à titre de personnes qui
étaient inscrite sous la Loi sur les
Indiens et là ça va soulever si ça
soulève justement l'idée du parjure
chez des personnes qui sont surrénistes
est-ce que on n'était pas en train de
demander à quelqu'un qui est encore vu
comme un pupille de la couronne de
porter à les gens dans le fond ce qu'on
appelait quand même la reine grand-maman
Elizabeth le grand papa Charles
est-ce que il peut porter à les gens
quand il est encore un mineur aux yeux
de la loi si ça va amener des questions
de droit des questions de droit des
questions de vétusté devis citer de des
lois mais aussi des changements de
société on se serait pas posé la
question s'il y avait pas eu justement
une personne autochtone élue si on a
envoyé pas justement parce que là on
parle pas des élections fédérales on
parle des élections provinciales et là
ça change aussi le la forme de qui tu es
comme élu et est-ce qu'on va faire
porter justement à notre nouvelle élu le
poids de porter la parole comme femme
autochtone et en plus comme
représentante de son parti est-ce qu'on
va l'opposer justement à des idéologies
de souveraineté qui sont composées
bibati autour d'une identité québécoise
à l'octone quand on veut essayer d'avoir
même une discussion autour de l'identité
autochtone dans la souveraineté que
c'est pas encore accompli donc très
intéressant à voir oui c'est vrai que ça
sert beaucoup plus à redorer l'image
d'un parti souverainiste mais ça va
amener des questions d'identité et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
intéressant de mon point de vue pour
voir comment est-ce qu'on va faire cette
discussion là comment est-ce qu'on va la
bâtir est-ce que ça va être fait d'une
façon respectueuse éduquée sur les
enjeux autochtones sur les doubles rôles
sur l'identité qui est porté par des
personnes qui ont des rôles et non pas
une identité de Premier ministre ou de
une identité tout ça ça existe pas une
identité de Premier ministre c'est un
rôle donc ou de ministres ou même d'élus
c'est c'est comment on s'est porté quand
en plus cette loi-là a est une loi qui
est porteuse d'identité la loi sur des
Indiens versus justement des allégeances
dans un format dans lequel tu t'es fait
lire dans laquelle tu as participé avec
tout ça c'est comme des entrecroisés que
je trouve passionnant et que j'ai hâte
de voir se développer mais ce sera pas
acceptable si c'est fait au prix de
l'instrumentalisation d'une femme
autochtone qui elle-même est en train de
porter un rôle comme représentante
autochtone dans une politique qui vient
de s'ouvrir à elle
comme toujours je viens d'avoir vos
retours genre de comprendre ce que ça
représente pour vous aussi donc
n'hésitez pas à partager des vidéos
n'hésitez pas non plus à nous envoyer
des questions je vous souhaite une belle
semaine